hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing how
Hogwarts Legacy may have just given us
an entirely New Perspective on the death
of beloved Hogwarts Headmaster Albus
Dumbledore Hogwarts Legacy takes place
in the late 1800s supposedly 1890 which
means that during the course of the game
Dumbledore is just a mere nine years old
however the thing that Hogwarts Legacy
exposes has nothing to do with
Dumbledore in that timeline but rather
it emphasizes an aspect of the law that
impacts Dumbledore many many years later
The Wizarding World in the 1800s was
still The Wizarding World and the rules
of this world are very much the same as
the rules in the Harry Potter time
period first we'll discuss his death
then we'll segue into how Hogwarts
Legacy changes it in chapter 27 of the
Half Blood Prince the chapter
dramatically named the lightning struck
Tower Dumbledore meets his demise at the
hands of Severus Snape Severus please
Snape raised his wand and pointed it
directly at Dumbledore Avada Kedavra a
jet of green light shot from the end of
Snape's wand and hit Dumbledore squarely
in the chest Harry scream of horror
never left him silent and unmoving he
was forced to watch as Dumbledore was
blasted into the air for a split second
he seemed to hang suspended Beneath The
Shining skull and then he fell slowly
backwards like a great Ragdoll over the
battlements and out of sight the passage
above references Dumbledore's death at
the hands of Severus Snape on the 30th
of June 1997 a pivotal moment in the
series that shocked the Wizarding World
to its core Dumbledore's death was a big
deal he was 115 years old and had made a
profound impact on the Wizarding World
over the course of his life his death
also raised a lot of questions how could
the wise and Powerful Dumbledore be
defeated in such a paltry manner the
first thing we need to dig into deeper
is how he died as this Bears immense
significance with regards to how hog was
Legacy may have impacted it typically
it's inferred that Snape's killing curse
Avada Kedavra was more than enough to
finish him off but one overlooked
component is his fall after being struck
by Snape's curse Dumbledore fell over
the battlements and out of sight but one
detail of significance is that his
origin was the astronomy Tower the
tallest tower at Hogwarts Castle since
Hogwarts Legacy came out players all
over the world have been trying their
best to connect the dots between the
in-game cannon and the existing series
and one such activity that has become
particularly popular is visiting the
place where Dumbledore met his demise
Atop The astronomy Tower Hope was at one
time entirely lost for The Wizarding
World but in the 1800s I doubt this
Tower possessed such an ominous
connection players all over Reddit have
chimed in on this matter and they also
seem to have noticed an issue with the
spot where Dumbledore fell one Reddit
user tipped off players you can go visit
the spot where Dumbledore fell of the
tower except that there's no way to fall
on the ground from there so they
continued to explain we can only assume
that canonically this is what happened
the redditor then included a diagram of
the Hogwarts Tower with an illustration
showing the most likely route of the
lighthead Masters fall and let's just
say Dumbledore's fall would not have
been Pleasant a far from linear drop
that would have had Dumbledore bouncing
around like a ragdoll however others
were quick to chime in with their own
feedback offering counter Arguments for
why this illustration of Hogwarts may
not be entirely accurate at least at the
time of his death
it's already been established that
Hogwarts has an ever-changing floor
pattern commented one Reddit user that a
throwaway line in the game that the
castle changes periodically and while
this is true I'm not entirely convinced
that the exterior of the castle would
have changed in such dramatic fashion
others added that perhaps the weather
would have played a role in influencing
Dumbledore's fall maybe it was a windy
night bodies don't drop straight down
especially if there was wind others
however had a different reaction man
that old man was bouncy whichever way
you look at it Dumbledore's fall would
not have been Pleasant even if he did
fall straight down and even if he had
been killed by the killing curse prior
to Falling it's not exactly a graceful
way to go but here's where I've got a
glimpse of Hope for some of you at least
the ones that are open to fairies I
don't think that Dumbledore died from
Snape's curse I think that the only way
he could have died was if he had
succumbed to the fall the reason that I
say this is that the curse used to kill
Dumbledore was none other than Nevada
cadavra which as we know requires Great
intent in order to be used successfully
even though it was part of their plan
I'm not entirely convinced that Snape
would have been able to master the true
intent in order to effectively strike
down the Headmaster but this still
leaves us with Dumbledore being blown
off the side of Hogwarts A fate witch
entirely by itself would have been
enough to bring the Headmaster to his
demise there are actually quite a few
ways that he could have a survived a
fool and B faked his death first I'll
discuss the potential ways that
Dumbledore could have stopped his full
mid-air and escaped the first
possibility surrounds a spell that we
actually see Dumbledore use in an
earlier film a Resto momentum which is
used to slow the velocity of an object
the next possibility is that Dumbledore
had a broom stashed somewhere and used
Akio to summon it mid-fall the next
possibility is that Dumbledore simply
operated we see Dumbledore operating
constantly and he seems to be one of the
only people not bound by the Restriction
of no operating within Hogwarts
Dumbledore placed at many of the
enchantments on Hogwarts so it's not
unreasonable to assume that he would
also be able to lift them the next
possibility ties into an old theory of
mine which suggests that Dumbledore is
in fact an unregistered animagus we know
for a fact that once Patronus form
generally provides insight into what
once an omega's form would be we also
know that Dumbledore's Patronus is a
phoenix so I'm suggesting this after
thrown over the battlements Dumbledore
simply turned into his Phoenix and
omega's form flying away everyone would
have thought it was just forks and on
that note my final explanation for how
Dumbledore could have prevented his fall
is that he was simply saved by Forks
caught mid-air and brought to safety
Dumbledore surviving the fall it's a
lovely thought but one big issue that we
still have to consider is his body
doesn't Dumbledore have an entire
funeral if he survived then how can his
motionless corpse be reasonably
explained well I don't think it's
entirely impossible to deduce that Snape
a potions expert could have created some
sort of concoction for Dumbledore to
drink upon his safe landing a concoction
that would bewitch the mind and snare
the senses and in a roundabout way but a
stopper in death it's also entirely
possible that Dumbledore and Snape had
used polyju's potion on an unnamed but
deceased Death Eater leaving the body of
that wizard behind while Dumbledore
escapes it should also be mentioned that
Dumbledore surviving doesn't impact the
plot that follows his death before his
death while still in possession of the
Elder Wand Dumbledore was disarmed by
Draco and it's been proven that
ownership can be gained simply through
disarming and does not necessarily
require death therefore Dumbledore
surviving does not disrupt the path of
ownership that the wand eventually
follows these theories may be a bit
far-fetched but I do like a good theory
and I certainly don't like to imagine
that Dumbledore fell brutally to his
death what do you guys think have you
noticed any aspects of Canon that
coincide with events in Hogwarts Legacy
leave a comment down below and until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]